it's five o'clock in the morning in
south eastern Turkey ma Gabriel is one
of the oldest Christian monasteries in
the world at first glance I seem to be
the only person here but I can hear
noises coming from inside the
monasteries church
they hold Messier every Sunday
I've come here to meet Petros he's one
of three young people my fellow
reporters and I will talk to during the
show three young Christians who want to
devote their lives to their faith but
I'm not allowed to the people here as
suriani a tiny Orthodox Christian
minority loving and Muslim Turkey my
gamma-gamma says you know and Massa
dadima at siffredi mischievous lenovo an
ohio enira have a knob Asamoah a
malevolent a tow ferret : a little
decision muga bonifay Zunino an interim
canoes estate moved for a loo titled
isothermal and I say Lohia Padano mad
know that William my furnace old Dublin
is Oconee so I don't find because I'm a
woman I have to stand at the back of the
church together with the nuns I feel
like I've traveled back in time the
suriani say the ritual stayed back to
the times of Jesus himself
they even speak Aramaic the same
language Jesus spoke
despite the rich history the suriani
don't enjoy the same rights as turkeys
muslim-majority they even face
oppression by the Turkish government
after the three-hour mess
I'm honored when the bishop the suriani
spiritual leader invites me over to talk
we don't have any rights in Turkey man
as Christians we don't have anything and
if you don't have right to teach our
language to teach our religion to beat
any churches and anything for us for
ourselves so why what is the human
rights where is the democracy where is
what are they - al mama didn't had an ad
for six years
Petros lived here as a child monk from
an early age he learned a life of
discipline and rules Petra shows me the
classroom where he spent every Saturday
studying aramaic until he was 15 during
the week the boys you go to regular
Turkish schools
trendy media very basic rotor coil Queen
available by Nina Simone I'm Susie hello
Marwat retired really Merle mm she hurt
oh ha ha ni Shu inactivation just a
hundred years ago most of the people in
this region rest suriani Christians I
wonder how the people here today deal
with this Christian heritage and
Buddhist monasteries O'Brien naka de si
que viven - Asami could sit both are
high he was emitting yahushua Chopra
this year she is Geritol Ashok Chauhan
excuse a Yanni Giada hi it's Jim
Szechuan do detective Nagle Manabu took
channel - and ostrich builded a Sunni
rendition of establish HP engine
I will good material is funny
I go to visit Petros and his family at
their home in a small Christian village
the family lives off the land selling
some of their crops to make little money
when I come they've all put on their
best clothing for my visit
Petros parents are proud that their
family has managed to stay here Anatomy
no Martina Waterloo lobbying aims at
emedco honey o @ q Marcus jingshu who is
working
Mahalo Deena Murphy no water clean
hammer Olivette mo among with fire key
look in MO finale he was was like 20
yell Petros and his eight siblings all
lived together with their family in this
farmhouse he makes it harder cannot halt
any heart okay he'll do a baby home
homily mama on a limit Ricardo Goro
Cabana by the midday guarantee bhai v/o
buzzer oh no trans knew that world
behavioral Roy hey Jana do Goro Laker
volley Yan eroded away for South Korea
Pavano
good on luan for now Pedro's works on
the farm it's unclear what the future
holds for him he wants to study
Christian theology but the universities
in Turkey don't offer it he also wants
to escape poverty that either means
marrying a girl from another country are
going to live in a monastery
we set up for the Turkish city of Medina
the deputy mayor there is the suriani
like Petros
Petros hopes she can give him some
advice since he wants a future here in
Turkey in the last century millions of
suriani have been forced to leave their
homes there are only 24 thousand left in
Turkey a quarter of a million suriani
fled to Europe over four hundred
thousand to the US we pass by a refugee
camp thousands of people have come here
from nearby Syria
to escape the terrorist group Islamic
state we finally arrived in the Turkish
city Medina Petros is nervous about our
meeting he wants to ask the deputy mayor
why it isn't possible for him to study
Christian theology at the University
here in Turkey even though the country's
Constitution guarantees freedom of
religion the reality is quite different
a close I'm sharing a new Madonna
Madonna glimse Dina Ali no shade lick
Bella new clothes I'm Anna la mesa de la
novia name was he a Holland Quixote
frozen for Heena Angelo dela Jenna
Madonna give it over you the Petra's are
surprised by her response sort of
Madonna Gras Friday yeah sure let me
leave the home made a no was it wala
homosexuality or in a bad
Maharani Whalen you do enjoy penis Amina
royal and manga Jersey which have an
eponymous each other so dramatically
I hope someday I'll get to come back
here I'm curious to see if Petros can
improve his situation and live his dream